we've been on hiatus for the last six
weeks when we went
on our break in late june we were hoping
to see college football played this year
um just the last week the big ten and
the pac-12
postponed their season till the spring
hoping to maybe start in january ryan
day just said maybe we start playing
eight games
starting in january um justin fields the
quarterback of the ohio state starting a
petition however to get the big ten back
on the field
and parents of the michigan wolverine
football team
um created a twitter account just today
to put out a statement saying that they
want to sit down with the big ten
commissioner and also the president of
the school to start saying hey
what did you base this stuff on while
the sec acc
and big 12 are still considering playing
football this year
so there's a lot of stuff all over the
map literally and figuratively
and um i i saw this uh gentleman i was
on cnn over the weekend and it was uh
reported uh just an uh a couple of uh
um written spots i i did not really get
to see the interview so i just
definitely wanted to chat with him
myself and i'm appreciative of him
calling into the show he is the
chief medical officer of the ncaa dr
brian hayne line how are you doc
well i'm doing well how are you rich i
am doing well so let's
uh i guess jump right in here um
where do you stand on the issue of
whether football
should be played collegiately this fall
dr heinlein
so so rich i stand in the the same place
as
uh the advisory panel that we put
together and and actually three other
medical groups which
include the the power five or autonomy
five medical advisory panel
we didn't weigh in and and say play or
don't play false sports we said
these are the rigid conditions under
which they must be played
and and and we actually included five
reasons not to play false sports and so
uh the big ten and then separately the
pac-12 they looked at all of that and
and and they made their own independent
decision that they didn't think they
could meet those criteria and
the sec acc and big 12 um
they postponed making a decision
and uh they said you know maybe
something will shift and we can meet
those criteria so
so that that's where we are it it wasn't
an ncaa top-down decision it was an ncaa
saying
these are the absolute conditions and
and these are conference decisions
well i guess part of the concerns uh of
those who are
petitioning the big ten and justin
fields to play and parents of michigan
just to
name just a couple of entities and
people that want to play
is that is that when you say um
conditions um and the conversation that
you have put
together um or at least the science that
you put together
uh of not to play that it seems to be
not
very well known so what are those
conditions that are out there that the
big ten heard and the
pac-12 heard and decided to move on from
football and fall sports right now
well so there there are a few things one
is that uh there has to be
a a testing program in place and and the
minimum amount of time to get a test
back
it has to be three days or less and then
frankly in most parts of the country
right now
it's taking seven to ten days to get a
test result back so that in and of
itself is
a national disaster and and shouldn't be
the case
um the the other is that uh you you you
have to be able to
uh look at where you are locally in
terms of your hospital
infrastructure that's one other example
and if they're at a situation where they
are close to imploding or are are very
filled
that's a reason not to be able to
proceed another is that you have to have
the ability to do
absolutely good contact tracing and in
the majority of this country right now
we are even close to being able to do
contact tracing we
we can barely even find out you know the
two close contacts let alone the 10
close contacts
and then another is you have to be able
to be certain that
you can fairly isolate and quarantine
all individuals that
that have to be in that situation and
your infection rate has to be at a place
that the local
public health officials say yeah this
this infection rate is acceptable and
what's interesting in our country
is that we don't have any national
guidance that's making it quite
difficult
and in some parts of the country the
local health officials say look this
infection rate is not acceptable
we can't be doing much of anything and
in other parts they have a different
interpretation
so you know with a new pandemic a new
disease you have
people looking at the same science but
they interpret it somewhat differently
and
and that's actually been the case when
we look at a lot of disease states in
our country
it's not just the black and white the
scientists say this it's also
how we interpret what the scientists are
saying so
uh dr brian hainlan the ncaa chief
medical officer here on the rich eisen
show a lot of those
criteria that you mentioned though it
does seem that a power five big time
school would be able to
uh get the testing and get uh and and
have the health care
uh at their uh uh ready now not every
school can
but some of the schools that have been
cancelled that want to play
might be hearing this from you doc and
saying you know
we could actually do that or we were
actually
doing that uh is there anything else
that was put on the table that
that that caused schools to essentially
tap out
on football well no it it it
really was uh you know we have to also
look at who's making the decisions
ultimately yes
and it's the presidents of the
universities and so the ivy league
president for example
uh you know before anyone else they said
look this just doesn't look like we're
going to be able to reasonably pull this
off and it has less to do
just with football as it has to do with
these are football athletes that are
going to be interacting with a large
student body
and we have no idea if we're going to be
able to keep this virus contained
even within the student body let alone
with the football team i mean they
control the football team for four hours
a day but then there's 20 hours a day
where
where things are quite variable and and
that that's the great difficulty with
this pandemic i mean
quite honestly when we started thinking
about fall sports
we really thought we were going to be in
a radically radically different place
than we are today
we had all the projections going in in
the right place and then
and then what happened is our our
country just moved in completely the
wrong direction and i think the
presidents are responding to that as
well
and so um the the testing as it
currently
is right now in the sec acc and big 12.
is that
do you think satisfactory for them to
eventually decide to play
not if it was today there's no way
anyone could if we were to play today
the very interesting thing and and i've
been saying this all along i
i don't think that the traditional what
we call pcr
tests or where you do the nasal or
nasopharyngeal swab you send it to a lab
i mean we're running short of reagent in
this country and
that test is taking a very long time and
in some parts of the country it's on a
priority basis meaning that only the
sick are tested so
then it's unethical to do testing in
that situation i think that
what the other conferences may be
holding off for is that
a different type of test is going to
emerge and indeed we saw
this weekend that a new saliva direct
test
has come about so this is something that
the nba was testing alongside their
traditional tests and they said hey you
know the results are not perfect but
they're pretty good
and i think some other of what we call
point-of-care tests meaning you get the
results back immediately
you aren't using scarce resources and
other labs i think those are going to
emerge and
and so uh if they really do emerge and
they become widespread and they're
available
well that's a paradigm shift it's a real
paradigm shift
dr brian heinlein the chief medical
officer of the ncaa
joining me right here on the rich eisen
show and that testing is something i
definitely want to
dig into a little bit deeper but if you
just hang on one second i do want to
tell all the audience here on nbc sn
that i'm sending you to nhl live with
catherine tappin
right now enjoy the first of four nhl
hockey playoff games right here on nbcsn
and i'm staying on the line with dr
heinlein for for the moment here so
um when you're talking about the testing
um and you're saying that these other
leagues are hoping that the testing
could potentially um uh
be satisfactory do you think it's
possible that the big ten
and the uh pac-12 under those
circumstances
might open up again is that something
that you're thinking is feasible
well i can't really speak for them but
there's a very interesting dynamic as
as you mentioned at the in the opening
about uh
parents and players wanting to be part
of the decision making as well and
and and so look these are dynamic
situations we we
haven't encountered in over a hundred
years when it when it comes to a
you know a very virulent and and quite
infectious disease so
um that could be a consideration and and
the other is well
what happens when they open up their
schools i mean they they have to decide
if
if that's going well too because i also
mentioned the other night that when we
really start opening up schools
we may find that uh that that's going so
poorly that we really can't consider
uh much of anything let alone sport so
uh but going back to your question about
the testing yeah
i think if they reopen the conversation
and again uh that's their their
conversation to have
um and the testing paradigm has shifted
that radically
yeah that's that's a real game changer
now another thing that we've heard in
reporting dr hainleine is that
the conversation um and the topic of
myocarditis
uh if i'm pronouncing that correct um
yeah
that uh the the issue involving
the heart and the inflammation of the
heart muscles that it can
uh hit anybody um due to
uh covet 19. uh we're seeing what
eduardo
rodriguez right um chris of the boston
red sox
he is he is suffering from it yes member
of the indiana football team i think a
freshman on the indiana football team
is is dealing with it what can you tell
fans about this because we're hearing so
much about this
and apparently this was the if you will
uh
sealer uh the game-changing sealer of
the decision for the big ten
and pac-12 commissioners to make their
decision
well so we've known about uh the
possibility of myocarditis really for
more than two months close to two and a
half months and
and and we've been talking about it and
now there are about a dozen case reports
of of college athletes who have
developed this so
so going back i can tell you i've been
in sports medicine a while
even 30 years ago i remember speaking at
a tennis conference for elite tennis
players and
and there were a group of scientists
saying that if you have any symptomatic
viral syndrome you should not be working
out because there's a chance of
myocarditis with any virus um
but it just so happens that uh in this
particular corona virus that for covid19
that the myocarditis is is probably more
severe
but we also work with a group of uh
cardiologists from the american college
of cardiology in the american medical
society for sports medicine
and and we developed a protocol for for
evaluating this and so essentially
any athlete who has had covert 19
undergoes
a three-part evaluation and so that's an
expense it's an added expense but
you can actually assess for myocarditis
and of course if you have it then the
athlete
sits out and if you don't well then the
athlete is clear so
this is what the professional sports
have been doing and we've also developed
a
a similar protocol so yes it's a
complication
um and it can be assessed for
and so today the sec is going to start
training and it's not just football too
this fall
uh doctor it's you know midnight madness
is just about
what six weeks around the corner usually
middle of october is when
college basketball programs begin to get
back
if what's the improvement in testing we
need to see that you is there is there a
problem even with you
advocating for the start of college
basketball here
well i think college basketball is is an
entirely separate conversation
and uh you know the one thing that makes
basketball different from football
is the frequency of the games and and so
you know it's not so much just the
practice it's really when you're playing
against another team
so you may do everything right you have
a you know
a semi uh permeable bubble and
and you don't want some other team
coming in and all of a sudden infecting
your team so basketball
that makes it even more challenging
because there are so many games and so
uh for basketball to proceed there
definitely would have to be a real shift
in testing but
but we can see that we're moving in that
direction so i
i would just say that there's a real
sense of optimism
and the ability to do diagnostic testing
and get the results within a day
okay we just aren't there today that's
the problem so what what
based on your knowledge and being i
imagine at the cutting edge of this in
the forefront and you must your phone i
mean i talked to dr alan sills of the
nfl
and you know he his his phone rings like
crazy when it comes to people saying i
got this test i got that test
your phone must be ringing crazy too um
so what can you tell people about what
you know about testing therapeutics
and and how this can actually begin to
change your belief from whether sports
can actually exist in our society
currently
well and i don't think it's even for
sports i i think you know so you
probably have
read recently about uh the paper test
and so
you know before you go on an airplane
before you go in a restaurant i mean
until we have a vaccine
if you can get a rapid test and you say
hey you know you want to come into my
restaurant
we're going to test you right now i mean
this is what we probably are going to
need to do as a society until we really
are certain that we have an effective
treatment
or a vaccine and and and most of us who
have
really been in the trenches and working
with all these individuals
we think that this is going to emerge by
the fall so
we already have the saliva direct test
that was approved by the fda that the
mba
uh helped to sponsor with their research
so that's going to be
available in the next several weeks we
have antigen tests that are definitely
going to be available in the fall and
and there we can get up to 50 tests in
an hour so
so it's all happening it's just that
if someone were to say should we be
playing competitive sports today based
on where we are
um well maybe we can train but we
shouldn't be playing
uh games today because uh the the
testing is still
i mean quite frankly it's more archaic i
mean when you really think about it
in in our country and the the the most
developed country in the world that
we're waiting
10 days to get a test it's um it's it's
just exceptionally disappointing to say
the least i would
i agree with you uh dr heinlein um you
know just a couple of minutes left with
you
i i want to ask you point blank do you
think there's going to be college
football in the fcc
big 12 and acc this fall do you think
that
oh boy well look i i think there is that
possibility i mean
that we've always said or at least you
know
dr rimmer and uh the president of the
ncaa and myself
yeah it's possible it's an exceptionally
narrow path
and there's treacherous waters on either
side of that narrow path but if
everything aligned perfectly
um it is a possibility well you
mentioned dr emmert and i
i want to give you an opportunity to
respond i'm sure you've you
you you might have heard uh the
criticism that the ncaa has received in
the last
week to 10 days on this subject alone
that in the same way that you say that
there's no national strategy
uh on testing and battling this virus
writ large
um many people would say that's the same
thing that's going on right now in
college athletics
uh dr haneline um that that right now
you're just letting
all the localities and municipalities
and states figure it out for themselves
and not come down from the top down and
say there is no football
there is no sports because of x y and z
how do you respond to something like
that
yeah and i i think it's a very fair
question and um
and what what is not appreciated really
behind the scenes is that when we put
out our last document which
actually is a mandate so every school
must follow it
and within that mandate every athlete
has the right to opt out of sport and he
still may
or she maintains their scholarship and
their eligibility
it wasn't just the ncaa that put this
document out it actually was endorsed by
the national medical association our
advisory panel
the american medical society for sports
medicine the power five medical advisory
piano and the
committee on competitive safeguards and
so you have this very very large group
of experts they all weighed in and said
the decision is not whether to play fall
sports or not
the decision is this is what must take
place to play these fall sports and so
with that in mind and and looking at the
wide variability across our country
uh we made the collective decision that
that really is a conference by
conference this isn't they know what
they must follow
um except when it comes to national
championships and so we did make the
decision on national championships
you know uh regrettably we we had to
decide to cancel all the fall
championships
but i think everyone knows or most
everyone knows that
we control 90 championships there's one
that we don't control
and that's the college football playoff
what we do control in the college
football playoff
is what the student athletes must
undergo and so
the mandates are for the student
athletes health and safety so they must
be followed but ultimately just because
of historical quirks
the college football playoff is also
decided by the conferences
dr heinlein i really appreciate the time
um and you know
so many fans just want to know that i i
again it just
it just seems that maybe a document of
exactly what you laid out for all of
these conferences
medically and the science and protocols
again just put putting it all out there
and saying this is what we have told all
the conferences and
maybe that is necessary would you
absolutely and we actually have put that
out there and so anyone can access it
it's ncaa.org
forward slash sfi okay
and this document is there along with
the frequently
frequently asked questions and um so we
put a wide release out there
you know sometimes it takes a lot of hit
everywhere
i've been on hiatus maybe that's where i
missed it but again it it just
just to see you know parents sending uh
creating twitter addresses to say
hey uh kevin warren hey you know dr
schlissel
we need to we need to meet you need to
tell us what you've been told
and you're saying this document is there
for everybody to be
to be aware of what the president of
michigan and the big ten commissioner
have been told it's there and actually
it's the third
uh document that we put out in this
series and and
and actually for the last 20 weeks we've
been discussing this on
what's called a social series weekly so
that everyone can hear our
our thought processes but you know
sometimes it
it it takes a a crisis for everyone to
then say hell yeah you know that's where
it is or
not now i find it because you know
everyone's busy doing other things or or
what have you but we really have tried
our best to socialize this and
and make it widely available to everyone
and and i love the feedback
you know when people read it because
look we're we're all trying to figure
this out
it's almost like one day at a time i bet
uh thanks for the call appreciate it and
look for my call again
uh i definitely obviously this is going
to be changing
and and hopefully for the better and we
can get you back on
okay well thank you for that you bet you
got it thank you that's
dr brian heinlein the uh chief medical
officer
of the ncaa